la famille
[Applaudissements]
donnez moi c'est la mémoire il donnait
moizer jean michel maire ouais tu vas
vraiment descendre parce que sinon c'est
moi qui vais te faire redescendre ne me
posais pas de questions
bassil a écouté oui c'est fait quoi
d'ailleurs ce week-end vous qui a fait
quelque chose de particulier c'est toi
qu'est ce t'as fait aussi on va se
calmer
qu'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire avec
les grèves donc j'ai marché j'ai marché
j'ai marché à la wii c'est beaucoup plus
cher en double avec ma vie ça va être
dur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hier des buts
elle est très belle elle est très bas
être même aller travailler sur les faits
vous moi j'ai fait une tennis poker et
puis pas de bernard montiel
alors moi j'ai vu des films en revanche
est très bonne solution pourtant les
fêtes arrive comme ça j'ai eu une petite
gastro j'ai perdu 1 kg 5 important car
lui aussi
ouais on vraiment inquiet le 5 g pas
bouffer pendant trois jours alors oui
parce que j'étais mal et c'est génial ça
juste avant de tenir tête à tête et en
gastro jugé non ça finit pas et tu sors
tu sais
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est quoi ce week-end on vous a
vu en photo vous vous avez de drôles de
tenues vous mettez des shorts avec des
doudounes ouais ouais learning battu là
bas il va vous montrer bonne et toi
qu'est ce tu as fait ton délire qui
souvent n'est fait moi j'ai fait les
courses de noël
enfin il était temps j'ai tout réussi à
acheter des cadeaux à tout le monde
c'est bon à tout le monde magazine même
ici n'ont que pour votre famille oui
d'accord bat rennes et tu veux toi
il revient il est tellement de lumière
c'est comme si non je suis bien ya
tellement de lumière c'est comme les uv
[Rires]
je suis au bout de ma vie avec ces
tickets en fin de chronique une enquête
de ben harper siano ta soit pas là
arrive le pot vie s'est fait un petit
peu extinct et la gueule mais normal
d'accord alors en fin de compte une
enquête de baba spéciale sur la relation
incroyable entre cyril hanouna et
laeticia hallyday n'a rien appris ça ce
week-end c'est incroyable mais en
attendant le moment qu'on attendait tous
jeudi dans pas longtemps peau c'est la
confrontation entre vous cyril et des
gens qui vous détestent ah ouais il a
quelques-uns vous poser la question pour
ou contre cyril hanouna la télévision on
aurait pu poser la même question souvent
à montiel mais ça fait dix ans qu'il
arrêtait la gêne et j'ai vu gad elmaleh
de thaler j'ai croisé gad elmaleh dans
la rue ma ti baba c'est parti très loin
on m'a dit ça y est on m'a dit il a fait
beaucoup de cyril hanouna
c'est important de le faire tabasser
très bien et donc vous avez accueilli
des gens qui ne peuvent pas vous
plairait blé l'été pmp way regardez
oui dit que c'était bien où j'ai
commencé à regarder je la regardais un
j'ai eu du mal 2-3 j'ai arrêté je crois
tu t'es tu tu ralentis a fait une
tentative de suicide d'humour là par
exemple
lui il vous aime beaucoup mais on a
découvert votre plus grande fan licorne
qui vous a fait 48 morts avant lui reste
dix minutes actuellement oui donc tu
voudrais quoi que je fasse quoi tout
sauf de la télé pour éviter de voir ta
tête d'accor pourquoi je t'aime pas
voici en fait ta façon d'être
tes rires de yale mais de yens mais
c'est sûr jouer c'est moi seras tu te
dérange matutu tous les regards seront
marc mon frère mon père mais moi je
comprends rien de quoi si
personnellement j'ai délaissé tpm pledge
ozap
je vois ta tête je peux plus mais c'est
bien ma gueule non mais le ballon
retombe au nord justement parce qu'avant
annulé c'était très drôle a dit elle
regarde ton post mais tu reviens dans la
zone oui mais quand tu parles de
josaphat l es et s était énorme ça
c'était un grand exceptionnel attention
et c'est un point on a vécu un moment je
vous dis exceptionnel première j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un parler cash comme ça
directement et non c'est énorme
faussement c'est vrai et voilà à bolelli
il y en avait un qui cherchait du
travail aussi que le jus c'est vrai il
est traîné ma wii en attendant c'était
très drôle mais voilà en tout cas on
sait où et mais la réelle craqué à la
fin j'ai senti un peu séduite comble des
arbres assez hauts je sais pas dit si
elle avait l'oeil qui pétille et alors
je pense que non mais roland moi c'était
sa première télé c'est vrai qu'elle
quitterait jamais passé l'armée sont
décollées éléphants elle reviendra enfin
pour ou contre
benjamin questions abordées foncez y en
avait un autre gars ajouter en plus
licorne avaient pas fini alors j'ai
voulu vérifier s'il avait raison ou non
moi je pense de sûr qu'elle se trompe
regardez en faire un peu moins les
meilleures blagues sont les plus courtes
bonjour moi pourquoi il dit ça parce que
c'est pas du tout votre style le comique
de répétition surtout pas sur les tenues
de lons ça y est et rose ameziane pas dû
vous êtes habillé vous êtes vous avez
dormi sur igor et grichka et igor et
grichka on est on est le temps est
dépassé on est donc temps il a donc
arrêté d'acheter leurs costumes à menton
et son magnifique nancéien oui c'est sa
première fois qu'elle y fume pas du même
avis que son frère jumeau grichka et
igor et grichka aussi rejoignez vous
avez vu qu'ils ont pris les combinaisons
d'igor et grichka toute façon les
meilleures blagues sont les plus courtes
et les duels se soient habillés avec des
trucs en aluminium
c'était très bizarre alors être est
blessé cette notion bien sûr ans est
très belle et que cette coiffure elle
sortait de la piscine alors serré si je
vous dis 48 heures ça vous évoque quoi
48 heures bah oui c'est en étudiant ces
48 heures c'est le nombre d'antennes que
vous faites par jour sur ses vitres
quarante huit heures par jour vous
assure on vous voit partout parce qu'on
voit partout tout le temps c'est le ses
nombreuses heures qui viennent qui
sépare également balances ton post la
jeanne d'arc a marqué 48 heures en fait
ces deux émissions très différentes et
vous allez autant dans l'une on parle de
la hausse du cac 40 que dans l'autre où
on a vu michel boujenah raconter des
blagues toutes les missions et c'est là
que je me suis aperçu vous étiez le roi
du grand écart parce que franchement ces
deux émissions que rien avoir regardé le
grand écart cyril hanouna syrie de van
damme taguil van damme tribulations
[Musique]
alors êtes vous pour ou contre
l'euthanasie la légalisation la
légalisation de l'euthanasie en france
petit récap et on en parle de sa vie
comme ça ça n'a pas
fèves qui est avec nous qu'ils
commerçante propriétaire d'un magasin de
jouets depuis quatre ans à paris alors
selon vous la grève doit-elle continuer
votre nuque et phonique supplique et toi
je veux la grève bloquent le pays suite
au nouveau régime de retraite annoncée
par le gouvernement
je suppose que tu suces pas l'ombre
[Musique]
eh bien je vais bien grâce à michel
boujenah et grâce bien d'audience de la
grand'mare cas j'aurai une nouvelle à
vous annoncer tout à l'heure oui vous
allez voir on a une idée ce week-end et
quand on a une idée le week-end
généralement sur ces huit ça va très
vite
l'amf avait quitté vous verrez il y à
une nouvelle émission n'est arrivée sur
s'est vite mais très prochainement
grâce à cette émission de samedi j'ai
appelé franck ap tôt dimanche matin le
président de la chaîne est aujourd'hui
sachez le ça vient d'être signé il y
aura une nouvelle émission qui a régné
sur ces huit là très vite que vous allez
présenter quel jour et biden malheureux
alors voilà mais vous verrez je vous en
dirai auquel jouent alors puisque ce
sera parti d'une question comment ou
pourquoi explique le dimanche vous
n'êtes pas longtemps vous verrez
couverte merci ok merci d'être là on
jeudi dans balances ton post s'est passé
que des trucs de ouf par exemple dit me
mohamed eric naulleau sont pas insulter
non la première fois jiminy cricket pas
du tout lui qu' il ya eu des choses que
personne n'a remarqué mais je voulais
absolument voulait montrer notamment le
retour de cyril hanouna roland garros
ses revenus regardez encore comme
pendant les débats c'est la nouvelle
c'est que sur le court philippe chatrier
aussi vous la betty et votre présence en
est la preuve c'est un espace et allons
à l'odeur de liberté d'exprimer
indirects mois l'année dernière j'étais
pour ça que ce soit d'ailleurs il m'a
même demandé de me calmer après en ce
sens n'avait toutefois pas preuve que
l'on peut dire ce qu'on veut on m'a pas
empêché de faire avant il m'a pas pris
le beck qui a perturbé la concentration
de cyril hanouna rester bizarre
[Musique]
combien de perturber surtout raquel
garrido et d'essayer s'exprimer
seulement en faisant des bruits
ça m'a donné envie de produire son
premier single big bang mais le nouveau
single de raquel garrido prochain tous
les meetings du canon choix
[Applaudissements]
ça fait bien
j'adore j'adore bon cyril vous êtes la
fleur que toutes les abeilles butinent
et j'ai remarqué ça ou quoi tout le
monde vous pechoux même clara morgane
vont donc clara morgane 6 à la c6 dans
la grande d'arc à samedi a clairement
fait savoir que vous étiez son délire et
ouf
si vous assure vous avez oubliez moi
j'ai vu là je voulais ce qu'il fait le
moment où vous êtes en train de vous
rendre compte que clara morgane c'est
qui accompagne et vous samedi soir
pendant des années et dans le calendrier
dans votre ford fiesta aussi d'ailleurs
que c'est vous attaquer c'est un nouveau
sondage ou pas du tout tu vas voir c'est
un nouveau soubassement le regard
regarder ça
[Musique]
attentionnée la branche ah oui parce que
la tortue à se dit je peux le faire
aujourd'hui on est en face je sens dont
les masques bien sûr bon alors clara
morgane bien sûr mais je compte sur
votre soeur aussi 40 familles pour finir
pour faire donc les acteurs à morieux
qui vous empêcheront et il paraît donc
que c'est pas la seule il est temps de
terminer avec la sphère du week-end à
cyril hanouna est il vraiment complètes
y aller franchement on se pose tous la
question alors c'est une nouvelle
enquête de boba lui c'est l'animal plus
connu sous le nom de cyril hanouna ce
week-end celui qui va bientôt quitter la
télévision pour devenir mannequin au
plaid décide de se rendre sur les champs
elysées et se met donc sur son 31
depuis qu'il présente balances ton post
il est obligé de lire les échos le monde
et bien sûr pêche info le meilleur de la
pêche au coup quand soudain il tombe sur
cette couverture non cette couverture
cyril hanouna serait en couple avec
laeticia hallyday pire encore ils
mettraient papa dans maman
ce ne serait pas étonnant père comme
denis ovb am change de couleur de
cheveux
il aime la boisson et surtout comme
denis cyril hanouna se prend pour un
chanteur
l'haïti sia aime les hommes musclés qui
ont une grande vivacité d'esprit du
coeur alors cyril hanouna est il
vraiment en couple avec la éthiciens
khalid dès que vous et cyril hanouna au
mariage de laetitia et denis en 1996 et
il est vrai que cyril hanouna et daniel
moreau ont vécu une belle histoire
d'amour pendant 30 secondes et surtout
mai est il vrai que cyril hanouna serait
en fait en couple avec mohamed benyamna
plus connu sous le nom de bouder autant
de questions auxquelles inspectés en
baba ne va pas les plaindre
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que cette couverture
exceptionnelle a franchement vision
d'ensemble
je vais revenir là dessus tout à l'heure
en fin d'émission forcément on aura les
infos bien entendu de bernard montiel a
un qui est au coeur du dispositif
il est au coeur du livre d'art et les
infos de pham ngoc qui est également au
coeur du dispositif n'est ce pas mon
fabien absolument pas franchement tu es
chaud là dessus après les jo tu as
toutes les infos il va tout va bien
ouais mon chéri que ça fait au smic end
juste pour savoir
j'ai travaillé puisque je suis à europe
1 deux de 18h à 20h tu fais une émission
sur europe 1 et oui avec wendy bouchard
non mes week-ends j'adore wendy bah
ouais tu fais quoi comme émission koala
le grand jour si tu fais quoi là bas je
raconte de la culture des chansons c'est
vrai raconte moi un truc un peu de la
mousse
non mais alors là ça m'a bloqué non
c'est vrai que j'ai tout pris dans le
dans le la dans le wimax 9 sur le alors
nantes 4 devrait dit raconte nos trucs
que tu as raconté la mesure grâce à un
bond à cédric leur prendra demain pour
sa chronique chez pas parce que c'est à
la disparition de anna karina 3d de
songer avec des déclarations très oui je
suis désolé mais nous a quittés samedi
matin oui donc j'ai la grande interprète
de serge gainsbourg est sûre sous le
soleil exactement
non la chanson 967 13 janvier 75
épisodes à la télévision à l'époque
d'accord c'est très important et puis
gainsbourg inspiré de neuf villes
inspiré vanessa paradis brigitte bardot
harley davidson
j'ai raconté mieux tu seras davidson
c'est quand il a lu les onze mille
verges de d'apollinaire c'est comme ça
qu'il a écrit dany ouais ça en fait des
messieurs se livrent les 1000 verges
vous l'avez jamais vu ça en fait tout ce
qu'on fait
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qui n'a pas son livre
qui lui a permis d'écrire avec davidson
dans un test mais quel rapport avec les
berges barré c'est le côté érotique
fantasmes sexuels
well as donné de 1907 c'est-à-dire 1916
les onze mille verges
adacore vingt sept